you know I sympathize with with the
Occupy people from this standpoint
they're sensing and we know it too if
the system is broken but it's broken for
different reasons than I think their
prescriptions are saying hi I'm Nick
Gillespie with Reason TV and today we're
talking with Chris Littleton a tea party
leader from Ohio and the head of Ohioans
for healthcare freedom Chris thanks for
talking to us hey thanks so much Nick
you're running a political action
committee to promote the passage of the
Ohio healthcare freedom Amendment which
is going to be on the ballot on this
November what would a yes vote on the
amendment accomplish a yes vote
basically creates what we say is
healthcare freedom in Ohio and it
accomplishes two things very directly
one we make sure that nothing like the
Massachusetts based system which is a
compulsory system can come to Ohio so
while we could certainly create a
state-based system compulsory
participation would never be possible
okay so you want to amend the
constitution of Ohio to say no
individual mandate at the state line
that's exactly right and the second
thing that it does and we were very
conscious of this in crafting is it
gives us a really unique standing
because this was citizen initiated to
have a very unique case move to the US
Supreme Court to question the actual
constitutionality of the individual
mandate from the federal health care
bill on a right space case which is
something that's very unique okay so
because the Supreme Court is clearly
going to be hearing the individual
mandate at some point so you think that
by having a constitutional amendment in
place you will actually have a better
standing to argue the case against the
mandate at the national level very much
so and one of the reasons why is because
one this was citizen initiated which is
very unique so assuming that this is
citizen ishi eight voted on by citizens
on November 8th and assuming that it
passes will be the only state that's
done something like that now why is that
important because it gives us some
interesting legal standing with the US
Supreme Court
we're also well I I'm definitely a
critic of the overreach of the Commerce
Clause being used to justify the mandate
something that we also very much we
think is extremely important in this is
that you know the Constitution also has
language very specific to citizenship
and more specific to due process
that if you're going to take away
liberty and property there has to be
some form of due process involved in
this case we feel as citizens but that
unique standing for those things are
fundamentally inhibited and we want the
US Supreme Court to hear our case on
them what are you guys polling at now
polling is about last Public Policy
Polling just released something last
week and it pulled at let's see 55 26 I
believe 55 we are winning 26 and 21
percent of voters were undecided if the
individual mandate in Obamacare or at a
state level is repealed or you know what
does that mean for the other elements of
Obamacare under your understanding or
interest in this there is an interesting
ruling from one of the judges in Florida
I was coming up through the federal
court system if you remove the
individual mandate as the means to
compel participation in this entire
thing that's the keystone of the entire
bill you could actually dismantle the
whole bill at that point so we we can't
control that but the courts may rule in
that direction and certainly we were
advocates of health care reform but we
like a more of a free-market approach to
getting those things done rather than
compulsory participation in a system
you're a big player and the tea party in
Ohio people are talking about
similarities between the Tea Party and
the Occupy Wall Street movement do you
see a similarity there and is there
anything that the Tea Party might learn
from the occupiers or occupants and vice
versa yeah I learning is an interesting
thing I think you know I sympathize with
with the Occupy people from this
standpoint they're sensing we know it
too I think every American knows it the
system is broken but it's broken for
different reasons than I think their
prescriptions are saying that how they
should be fixed out other solutions I
completely agree and I think most people
do I was certainly somebody that was not
happy to see tarp take place that was a
very very fundamental infringement in
free markets and created a lot of the
current problems that we have now I
think we've perpetuated this idea
too-big-to-fail for far too long and
they're feeling that to know they're
interpreting it differently but
certainly the idea of corporatism or
corporate statism is alive and well in
the United States and banks and big
business have gotten way too dependent
on government government favors
government lobbying favors do you see a
way
that the two party people might reach an
out talk about Wall Street you think
that after that initial kind of
revulsion at the bailouts you know
really there's very little in common
unless the prescriptions for solutions
change I mean it's really worse things
seem to divert it seems that their
answer to things is confiscation of
wealth which we would obviously
fundamentally disagree that that's the
route that you should go
we'd advocate for legitimate and true
free market systems rather than what we
have right now and we think that
capitalism when it is true capitalism
it's it's risk and reward legitimate
risk and reward is it's great for
everybody we've been talking with Chris
Littleton a tea party leader and one of
the head honchos behind Ohioans for
healthcare freedom Chris thanks for
talking great thanks so much Nick I'm
Nick Gillespie for Reason TV